if you have somebody in a leadership
position who who literally doesn't
respect uh diversity and and inclusion
um you know the question is why are they
in a leadership position what what
companies with with resources can do is
build their own bench which is go to
universities you know uh invest in the
programs that will train the people
train uh in this case as you said some
gender diversity so that they have the
skills and then uh and offer them the
potential for jobs when they come
through the the program so you set them
up in other words build your own bench
because I've heard this from companies
before which is you know we'd love to
but the talent's not there you know so
go build the bench if you have a
long-term approach to this stuff it's
not about solving a problem in a month
you know it's about solving a problem
um so that it's sticky so it's not just
a reaction but rather it becomes
inculcated and built in into the fabric
of the company
um and and I go back to leadership
training again
um which is what good leaders recognize
is that a a diverse Workforce Britain
diversity of points of view if everybody
looks like me went to a similar school
as me you know uh was was brought up
like me
um then we're all going to have kind of
similar uh points of view on some of the
challenges we face but when we have
people with different racial um
backgrounds or or different or different
genders we you know some people grew up
in Europe versus America or Rich versus
poor they bring entirely New
Perspectives based on their world view
to a problem and the more diverse
perspectives we have on any challenge it
means the more options we have to solve
that problem and so I think one of the
things to do is uh that leaders will are
going to be expected to embrace this
um that we're going to be judging our
leaders and their ability to do this to
build
um uh more diverse teams and to go out
into the marketplace to to before before
these some of these young people start
looking for jobs and start training them
in the skills that you want
um and setting them up it goes to what
we said before which is we want to make
you a whole person we'll give you some
of the technical skills and some of the
human skills and then when you join us
you're going to be a better prepared uh
a person a better prepared employee to
join to join our team because we've
already set you up for success with hard
skills and human skills